that's was a bit start there's a bit
later the start um playing this five
minutes of the game here against who's
um this Egypt Paraguay I hate it not
para wife this wrong flag guessing I
Egypt is entirely different it has some
black in there sorry paraguay yeah yeah
okay so we have a Rubenstein and funny
enough he's taking on c3 without me i'm
playing a three so i basically have the
same share with them with them yeah with
an extra temple quite quite funny well
this is playable for black it's not it's
not totally crazy but it's not really a
100-percent respectable line it's
something that i had looked at for my
book because it would be I would have
been very consistent with the approach i
had taken in other lines getting this
dark square blockade but it's simply not
not as good as some some other than
other lines okay i'm going here first
two to put some more cabin on f4 the
problem in this position is of course
that black is completely passive you can
know you can only wait what what i'm
going to do okay um king over okay let's
just continue on the Kings side I can
get the King here and then to a one
they're simply not much happening and
I'm completely overwhelming on the Kings
side with this with this space advantage
yeah well be five it opens a black skin
for first and foremost um okay so I mean
b5 is just just good for me don't mind
that I want to play night at five in a
in a situation where you cannot even
take it as G 7s hanging yeah now the
problem is also that there are
sacrifices looming on c5 and c6 I wonder
if I play Queen f2 how does he even
prevent me from sacrificing on c5 don't
don't see how really yeah well I can
take on d6 now Queen d6 Bishop c5 wins
the Queen Queen to King takes Bishop c5
wins the Queen as well to complete
devastation yeah this is simply
completely unplayable I'm sorry this um
this type of position is just terrible
like it's completely busted on the King
side and you have no play whatsoever the
only thing that you can try is to set up
a complete blockade like like like not
going over with a king but let's say
play something like that try to provoke
me to play h5 they have this move and
this is just this is just a possible
line that's simply not good for black to
bishop against two nights I control all
the relevant squares so one possibility
and there's simply no compensation for
this space disadvantage White has got
this huge wall of porn see on the kings
island like has no play you can just sit
and wait um this is really not not a
good
position simple simple as that in many
of those blocked positions with c 5 D 6
and d5 like in the huebner variation for
example I can show you like this this is
the classical huebner variation yeah I
note that this is the same situation in
the center it's completely identical to
to our game but here well both Kings our
Castle short and I cannot so easily
bring up my party and expand and if I
should try to do that white can do that
trying to move the night here for
example let's say like this for exams
the sample line black can play against
like this form or black and sometimes
even though go for f5 himself in the
game you had the same central situation
but I had the night here so and I've got
cancelled so I can easily push all the
porns him to ER to the space advantage
and this is just stopped not a very good
position I mean cannot um you can play
that but it's very very passive was
black and in the game he had tried this
a 6b five maneuver which is I think just
suicidal don't see black saving this now
after this yeah Queen f2 yeah he
probably should take here and try to
play this this type of position yeah his
king is not secure I still have the
space well this however was of course
completely completely over and he
resigned immediately this capture this
very early capture here is something
that I had had looked at for my book
get the desired structure but it's
simply too early even if you try to play
like that with 96 this loss of a tempo
compared to the to the samish with a 3
it's just a bit too much it's not really
good alright thanks for watching